it was the first country in the world to
use Bitcoin as a national currency now
El Salvador's poised to take its gamble
further
the president in a fireworks fueled
party announced that he's planning a
whole city based on the cryptocurrency
what is it consider going to include and
it's going to include everything
residential areas commercial area
services but we'll have zero income tax
zero capital gains tax
so you you know invest here make all the
money you want
we're fine because this is a fully fully
ecological City that's work that works
and it's energized by a volcano
Bitcoin City shaped like a symbol of the
cryptocurrency itself
it'll run with geothermal electricity
from the nearby volcano which will also
be used to generate more Bitcoins it's
an Investor's fantasy but there are
worries it's little more than that why
is that why are there doubts about it
among other things because there is no
study at this point that the conchawa
volcano which is the volcano that the
government has claimed will be the one
they'll be using for mining actually it
allows for that kind of geothermal
exploitation yeah her association's been
critical of president bukeli but many
bitcoiners are also skeptical nobody's
seen any detailed plans
but the government's still plowing ahead
planning to sell one billion dollars
worth of so-called Bitcoin bonds half of
which would be used for the city's
infrastructure the other half would be
used to buy up more Bitcoins the hope is
that their value goes up and helps pay
off some of El Salvador's large national
debt El Salvador's finances aren't
looking too Rosy it's been running up a
big budget deficit has payments looming
it's been trying to negotiate alone with
the international monetary fund but so
far that hasn't come through yet
hoping the Bitcoin volatile currency
which the IMF doesn't approve of the
country using will help solve the debt
problems represents an obvious Gamble
meanwhile El Salvador's first Bitcoin
experiment using the cryptocurrency's
legal tender along with the dollar
continues
government allies say it's doing great
but in four months of Bitcoin over 4
million people have become digitalized
and the vast majority of them didn't
have bank accounts and that's over
two-thirds of the population the
question is how many of those four
million people just use the government's
Bitcoin app once to get out the thirty
dollars worth of the cryptocurrency
given away for free
who knows no public stats are available
what is known is that people have
struggled to use the app and the Bitcoin
cash points from the start
I've been trying to get into my account
for two weeks and I can't do it it's
active and registered and I've been
calling support but they haven't been
able to sort it for me
the governments came to remind that it's
early days yet but with the newly
planned Bitcoin City and bonds it's
certainly up the stakes and it's bet on
cryptocurrency John Holman Al Jazeera El
Salvador